public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'ancien premier ministre et futur ex
élu c'est votre choix
jean pierre raffarin et jean pierre
raffarin notre invité bonsoir et merci
d'être avec nous pour ce rendez-vous de
public sénat avec la fp avec radio
classique avec les échos trois questions
vous seront posées ce soir par jean
francis pécresse marque réel et mickaël
szames s d'abord économies notamment
dans l'armée un c'est un point sensible
pour vous un pot réforme le compte est
il bon selon vous après la volte-face de
l'exécutif deuxième question les
constructif et l'air doivent-ils
toujours craindre les longs couteaux ou
même si l'exclusion ne semble pas à
l'ordre du jour ce soir
troisième question et vous maintenant
jean pierre raffarin et bien vous ne
parlerez tout à l'heure de vos nouveaux
projets ils sont nombreux une fondation
sur laquelle d'ailleurs vous pourrez
lever le voile
quand vous aurez bien sûr rendu votre
mandat de sénateur c'est prévu pour le
mois d'octobre mais d'abord une toute
première question d'actualité
[Musique]
la route semble se dégager mais on peut
le dire elle se dégage pour paris 2024
avec la notion de la double attribution
à 2024 ou 2028 qui a été approuvé tout à
l'heure par le cio à lausanne où la
france a donc présenté son grand oral
emmanuel macron en tête il l'a dit le
chef de l'état la france est prête pour
les jeux elle les attend est ce que vous
aussi vous les attendez oui c'est une
nouvelle bon soir michel russian bonsoir
à toutes et à tous
je suis heureux de participer à cette
dernière émission en tout cas pour vous
de la saison pour moi dans ce statut est
de pouvoir répondre ainsi à vos
questions je pense que cette décision
est très importante parce que un nouveau
refus pour paris on était quand même une
insolence donc il était bien qu' on
puisse avoir cette perspective et je me
réjouis que le président de la
république est tenu a présenté ce projet
comme un projet sobre de jeux olympiques
dans ce contexte là je pense que la
france il ya beaucoup à gagner même s'il
faudra être vigilant sur les coûts alors
il est engagé mais pas que lui on le
voit il ya la mère de paris la
présidente de région donc madame hidalgo
madame pécresse
ça montre que en fait toutes les tout le
monde peut se mobiliser aux deux écrit
un consensus au delà des divergences
politiques quand un enjeu capital
je pensais cause l'image de la france
dans le monde c'est quelque chose de
très important parce qu'en font la
france ait une influence plus puissante
que sa seule économie et donc nous avons
besoin de cette image l'image fondée par
notre place par exemple au conseil de
sécurité à l'onu
donc on a à part notre histoire
évidemment par nos grands hommes par nos
leaders est donc par l'élection d'un
jeune président de la république disons
le clairement l'élection d' emmanuel
macron a été l'occasion de re dynamiser
un peu l'image de la france dans le
monde donc tout ceci est très important
les jeux olympiques y contribuer à
condition aussi que nous tenions compte
de l'air du temps et l'air du temps ce
n'est pas la course la puissance la
course à la richesse d'un constat la
démonstration de force
c'est au contraire la sobriété à la
qualité des productions vous savez bien
qu'on n'ait jamais mettre des dérapages
financiers rien
bien sûr mais d'autres villes ont connu
cela je porte d'autres villes en ont
souffert mais je pense que la une paris
de bright innovantes pour essayer de
montrer que l'on peut faire aujourd'hui
des jeux olympiques qui sont autre chose
que la course à la démonstration
puissance à 40 ou les cas vous n'hésitez
pas à donner des bons points au
président de la république l'a lui il a
fait le déplacement aujourd'hui à
lausanne
contrairement à donald trump 1 je pense
que donald trump peut-être guère
intéressés comme quelqu'un d'
imprévisible il voyait plus seront
propres prévues dans cette situation
alors justement est ce que c'est parce
qu'il est un projet imprévisible qu'il
faut qu'il ne faut pas hésiter à
dérouler devant lui lui le tapis rouge
c'est ce que va faire la france dont le
14 juillet avec cette invitation du chef
de l'état je pense que c'est une bonne
chose
on célèbre une bonne méthode à cette
occasion des vraiment des combats pour
notre liberté on sait que les américains
on joue un rôle très important dans la
reconquête de notre liberté donc il faut
savoir avoir de la mémoire et donc plus
que monsieur trump c'est le président du
peuple américain qui est notre peuple
libérateur qui avec d'autres inquiets
reçu donc je pense que le jour de la
fête nationale
cette initiative est bienvenue même si
je pense que monsieur trump est plutôt
un facteur de déséquilibre dans le monde
actuel plutôt que un élément
stabilisateur quelqu'un en matière de
politique étrangère qui est imprévisible
et quelqu'un de dangereux
la suite de l'épreuve de vérité tout de
suite avec jean francis pécresse le
directeur de la rédaction de radio
classique
[Musique]
enfin michel bonsoir jean pierre
raffarin alors le ministre des comptes
publics gérald darmanin a annoncé ce
matin dans le parisien un plan
d'économies de 4 milliards et demi
d'euros sur la seule année 2010 est est
ce que ce compte est ce que le compte de
ces économies vous semble bon d'abord
est ce que vous
je pense qu'il est nécessaire de faire
des économies je pense que ce niveau
d'économies est sans doute à un niveau
plancher
néanmoins je suis très inquiet on joue
environ pour un certain nombre de budget
parce que il y avait d'abord des
engagements qui sont pris et puis il ya
des négociations qui doit être mené
vous savez que la procédure budgétaire
habituel c'est un ministre qui va
rencontrer le secrétaire lecteurs budget
qui explique ces projets le secrétaire
d'état au budget fait une proposition de
budget et si on n'est pas d'accord on va
en arbitrage et le premier ministre l'a
un article de presse annonce des
chiffres en ce qui concerne par exemple
le ministère de la défense s'est
complètement avant par antagoniste avec
ceux qui ont ce qu'on était des
décisions du conseil de défense
précédemment on écoute si vous voulez le
ministre des comptes publics justement
il était interrogé ce matin car le
chiffre n'est pas officiel le chiffre
des économies mais il circule
abondamment on écoute ce matin monsieur
d'harmonia j'ai calculé 850 millions
économisés la défense 530 à l'intérieur
160 à la justice a fait un milliard et
demi à peu près sur ces trois ministères
sensibles rogner sur la sécurité des
français
absolument pas nous avons travaillé avec
monsieur mise intérieur madame la
ministre de la justice madame la
ministre des armées pour trouver des
économies lui 150 millions à la défense
on peut dans la période trouvé cette
économie sans fragiliser
la protection des français mais le
budget 2010 est de la défense de bougera
pas ce que je veux vous faire comprendre
c'est qu'il n'y a pas d'économies sur le
budget voté par le parlement
il ya quand même un gel qui est annoncé
il ya d'abord un gel de crédits
y aura-t-il des gels et là on dépasse le
milliard donc presque à deux et donc là
il ya une vraie question qui est posée
et puis on voit bien que les engagements
du dernier conseil de défense qui ont
été de nature à redresser la courbe des
investissements militaires
ces engagements la honte il a tenu donc
pour le moment je ne condamne pas mais
je trouve que la démarche est précipitée
et que le parlement ne peut pas accepter
d'être mis devant le fait accompli de
cette nature alors 850 millions d'euros
que ce soit des économies ou un gel il
n'empêche que le résultat est à peu près
le même c'est à dire que les armées
françaises en 2010 et doivent se serrer
la ceinture
est ce que c'est une faute est ce que
vous est ce que vous considérez en tant
que vous étiez jusqu'à il ya quelques
jours je crois le président de la
commission des affaires étrangères et
des forces armées je le suis encore
aujourd'hui vous n'êtes encore
aujourd'hui ben voilà jusqu'à demain
jusqu'à d'un bon est ce que vous
considérez que c'est une faute c'est une
faute
c'est une faute nous venons de publier
un rapport très clair ici au sénat sur
un objectif de 2% qui correspond aux
engagements du président de la
république pendant sa campagne et
l'audace du pib ou 2% et d'événements
sont nés avant cela cette course
absolument et donc cela veut dire grosso
modo que il faut faire un bond de 2
milliards en par an pour atteindre cet
objectif mais il faut voir d'abord que
nous avons plus de trente mille hommes
aujourd'hui engagés dans des opérations
extérieures ce sont des opérations
extrêmement difficile qui sont
épuisantes avec des équipes qui n'ont
pas toujours les moyens de leur combat
est donc via sur le plan matériel comme
sur le plan moral
la nécessité de soutenir nos amis et
surtout de leur donner les moyens de nos
ambitions
parce que le pire c'est de leur donner
beaucoup d'ambition et peu de moyens
donc si on ne réduit les moyens
réduisent
ambition on réduit les moyens ce
quelqu'un est mon réduit la sécurité ce
qu'on met en péril la sécurité de la
france en tout cas et il est clair qu'on
sera obligé de réduire des opérations
extérieures et la sécurité mais donc
mais donc la sécurité parce que si on
est engagé et c'est pour notre sécurité
et donc si on réduit notre engagement
c'est quand on réduit notre sécurité
donc je pense qu'il y a là un certain
nombre de sujets qui doivent être
débattues je pense que il s'agit là de
préannonce que nous aurons des
discussions mais nous avons entendu un
la ministre des armées à la commission
du sénat la semaine dernière je pense
qu'elle est déterminée à se battre dans
la ligne de ce que sont les conseils de
différent un peu de prises de cookies
engagements du président et donc je
pense que là le comme d'habitude bercy
lance ses premières ces premières salves
de manière à bien le dire tout le monde
qu'il faut penser aux économies et puis
nous allons avoir un certain nombre de
négociations
moi ce que je dis c'est qu'un
gouvernement ne peut pas demander à ses
soldats
un niveau d'intervention aussi fort que
maintenant sans leur donner les moyens
de ses interventions
est-ce que vous en êtes ce que vous en
appeler solennellement au président de
la république et le chef des armées pour
le dire ne touchez pas au budget de la
sécurité nationale française nous avons
été voir le président de la république
pour lui donner nos propositions et nous
avons cru comprendre qu'il avait une
réaction positive à nos propositions
nous sommes dans un processus qui vient
de s'engager
nous voterons le budget à la fin de
l'année 2010 est donc il y encore des
négociations donc je ne mets pas le
couteau sous la gorge à quiconque
aujourd'hui mais je dis que clairement
nous ne pouvons pas donner à nos soldats
des missions sans leur donner les moyens
de ses missions vous ne le sait ces
sujets là certaines questions d'éthique
de responsabilité pour les élus du
peuple pour les dirigeants de ce pays
on n'envoie pas des soldats au feu si on
leur donne pas les moyens d'assumer
leurs responsabilités mais les
assurances que vous aviez reçu du
président de la république lui même
c'était le 20 juin vous étiez dans son
bureau
absolument elles se sont envolées alors
écoutez nous sommes dans un processus
qui démarre je ne veux pas aujourd'hui
présupposés de la fin des négociations
dans les dunes faute quand même mais je
pense que si nous en restons en orient
là ce serait une faute et je pense que
d'une manière générale il faut sur ces
sujets là écouter naturellement les
ministres et écouter aussi le parlement
mais par exemple quand je vois que les
crédits sont coupés sur le ministère des
affaires étrangères en matière de
coopération et l'aide au développement
jeudi l'attention comment est ce
qu'aujourd'hui on peut lutter contre le
terrorisme par la guerre mais aussi par
le développement
si on n'aide pas un certain nombre de
pays à cibler je prends l'exemple de la
tunisie
vous avez deux millions de réfugiés
libyens qui sont en tunisie sur dix
millions d'habitants
si on n'aide pas la tunisie à se
développer il est clair qu'il ya là une
fragilité pour la tunisie mais aussi une
fragilité pour nous donc les crédits du
ministère des affaires étrangères sont
particulièrement importants dans cette
situation de guerre dans laquelle nous
sommes donc ce que nous souhaitons c'est
qu'il y ait des discussions avec le
parlement bien sûr d'abord entre les
ministres mais ensuite avec le parlement
pour le moment je ne peux pas crier à l'
incendie
quand il y a que quelques foyer
d'inquiétudes qui sont exécutés la
négociation va je l'espère régler ces
sujets est ce que vous avez le sentiment
néanmoins que d'une certaine manière des
ministères qui sont des priorités
nationales ne sont pas en train ou ne
vont pas payer pour des baisses d'impôts
qui de votre point de vue sont peut-être
excessivement coûteuse est ce que est ce
qu'on peut mener de front la labège les
déficits et la baisse des prélèvements
obligatoires
je crois qu'on peut mener de front ces
deux objectifs mais je pense qu'il faut
aujourd'hui puisque nous sommes en
guerre
tenez compte de l'impact régaliens de
notre politique est donc qu en matière
d'action de sécurité de défense et de
diplomatie
je pense qu'il faut là un secteur qui
soit un secteur protégé ou alors disons
le clairement nous changeons le niveau
de nos ambitions et nous demandons à nos
forces
pour le diplomate d'avoir une politique
qui n'est plus la même
il yad'autres sur lui s'il ya d'autres
options par exemple je ne pourrais pas
demander à l'europe nos partenaires
européens ont gelé refont de participer
à notre effort militaire qui est un
effort que nous assurions pour
l'ensemble du continent européen au
moment où les américains sortent de la
protection du bien sûr on peut le
retenir des concours et on voit
d'ailleurs qu'il y à des avancées sur ce
sujet la défense européenne progresse
cela dit nous sommes sur une question de
souveraineté est là pour le moment on a
envoyé nos troupes
ce sont nos soldats ce sont nos
régiments et ce sont nos responsabilités
et donc on ne peut pas aujourd'hui leur
couper les moyens
alors que on est en train de négocier
avec c'est nous qui les avons envoyés au
mali c'est nous que les envoyons syrie
mais c'est nous qui leur demandant de
participer à la libération de mossoul
donc c'est notre responsabilité et la
souveraineté de la france se place là
donc moi je tiens à ce que la france
assume ses responsabilités et qu'elle
dise clairement seul si elle réduit les
budgets
parce que qu'elle réduise les missions
non justement scalpel négocié avec le
oui oui métaux qu'elles n'aient un
fourreau périmés vous pouvez pas
demander à la commission vous pouvez pas
demander à des soldats qui se battent au
mali par 40° dans des conditions leur
matériel et usé mais je vous parlais
chaleur vous prépare à dire attendez je
vous paie pas maintenant tels moyens ou
tel moyen parce que je négocie avec tel
pays je suis d'accord pour qu'on négocie
je suis d'accord pour qu'on fasse payer
les autres mais les responsables du
musée que l'on doit les assumer
on attend à court terme car nous sommes
en première ligne bon d'accord est-ce
qu'on pourrait de est-ce que ça
justifierait au fond la nécessité de
financer des baisses d'impôts et en même
temps de préserver un certain nombre de
priorités qu'on relâche peut être un peu
la bride sur les déficits publics est ce
que le 3 parce que le 3% en 2018 est ce
qu'il faut s'y tenir
non je ne pense je ne pense pas qu'il
faille relâché le combat sur les
déficits
je pense que emmanuel macron a réussi à
redonner
une image très européenne de la france
et je pense que angela merkel et les
autres dirigeants européens honte avec
ses attitudes et ces messages une
certaine bienveillance vis de la france
mais il va de soi que si nous ne sommes
pas au rendez vous d'une bonne gestion
cette bienveillance s'effacera s'ouvrira
donc nous devons rester donc on a un
certain nombre de sujets sur lesquels on
peut faire des économies
je pense notamment nous l'avons dit sur
la digue dégressivité d'un certain
nombre d' aides sociales liées notamment
à l'emploi parce qu'on a une politique
de l'emploi que nous voulons relancer
par une baisse des charges
il y un certain nombre d'initiatives qui
doivent être prises nous pensons que
c'est faisable mais est naturellement je
ne dirais pas que c'est facile puisque
nous sommes dans une situation quand on
voit les différentes annonces qui sont
faites ici ou là sur les coupes
budgétaires mais aussi sur la fonction
publique nombre de suppressions de
postes le rétablissement du jour de
carence dans la fonction publique est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment que le
gouvernement s'y prend bien écouter à
chaque discussion budgétaire
à partir du moment où les lettres de
cadrage ont été envoyés on a un certain
nombre des côtes presse où naturellement
bercy annoncé ces vérités et les autres
essaient d'organiser leur résistance
donc le rendez vous sont les arbitrages
du premier ministre qui ont lieu dans le
courant du mois d'août et la
présentation à l'automne du budget
jusqu'à ce moment là nous vivons que les
choses qui sont assez normal du canadien
où trouver ces légitimes pardon le gel
du point d'indicé votre style justin
rose je pense que c'est une décision sur
lequel il ya un engagement qui a été
pris
oui que c'est que c'est une décision qui
est nécessaire car hélas mais c'est une
décision nécessaire mais je trouve que
le jour de carence c'est une
c'est une bonne initiative je trouve que
dans la politique qui est menée il ya un
certain nombre d'aspects positifs
il ya des aspects sur lesquels nous
sommes en désaccord c'est pour ça que je
plaidé pour qu'on ait du viet études
constructive que tout l'attitude du
sénat c'est qu'il ya des sujets sur
lequel nous sommes d'accord exemple à 40
du budget sur lequel nous sommes moins
d'accord mais on voit que le
gouvernement a pris son temps c'est sur
la taxe d'habitation
donc il ya un certain coeur
si j'allais sur lesquels il ya chez nous
une résistante aux dernières questions
réponses brèves est-ce que sur est ce
que vous trouvez normal que le président
de la république qui s'exposent beaucoup
sur des sujets très sympathiques comme
les jeux olympiques ne s'exprime pas du
tout sur des sujets qui sont peut-être
plus plus lourd et moins populaires ceux
de la fiscalité ou des économies dans la
dépense publique
je pense que le président de la
république a intérêt comme il
effectivement à ne pas être trop bavard
et je pense qu'une parole sobre et ce
qu'il convient aujourd'hui au pays on
attend du président de l'autorité et par
une animation pollitt son nom vous parle
d' explication nous pas d'animation je
pense qu'aujourd'hui on attend du
président de la république tabou qui
sont arbitrés qu'ils puissent décider on
essayait de ce que ce que nous attendons
du prix amplifié réussi de l'autoroute
mais vous savez dans une démocratie il
faut choisir le moment où on explique
quand le budget sera sur la table le
président s'exprimera mais dans toutes
les phases intermédiaires
quand il ya encore des incertitudes et
avant que les arbitrages il ya toute une
animation politique dans cette animation
la parole présidentielle doit être sobre
je suis heureux de voir que c'est la
volonté de m on attendra encore un peu
donc merci beaucoup aussi bien francis
la suite de l'épreuve de vérité avec
l'actuel de l' agence france presse qui
nous rejoint l'épreuve de vérité avec
les faits
pour soi remarque bonsoir monsieur
raffarin pour soir alors ce soir on s'en
réjouir vous êtes avec nous le bureau
national des républicains se réunit vous
n'y êtes pas il doit statuer sur le cas
des membres du gouvernement issus de l
air soit aussi de le cas de député lr
qui soutiennent le gouvernement
vous n'aviez pas envie de participer un
tribunal non j'ai pas envie de
participer ni un tribunal ni à des
jugements de coupeurs de tête je crois
que clairement nous sommes dans une
crise qu'il faut regarder en face on a
perdu ses élections présidentielles kong
rendent partie de notre faute on avait
quand même un potentiel politique assez
incroyable un ancien prêt à la
république
deux anciens premiers ministres une
jeune génération et tout ça avec nos
primaires avec notre organisation tout
ça nous a conduits à l'échec il faut
regarder cela en face et dans l'échec
vaut mieux chercher à ouvrir qu'à
exclure
donc moi je ne suis pas pour les
exclusions je pense que aujourd'hui
personne ne peut se dire je suis
suffisamment fort pour dire que j'ai
raison et que l'autre à tort
aujourd'hui il nous faut débattre
discuter nous respecter et personne ne
peut dire aujourd'hui que edouard
philippe que ce n'est pas quelqu'un de
très bon niveau de grande qualité comme
c'est pas la question et ça fait
toujours partie de votre famille
politique l'est mais est-ce que j'ai
intérêt est ce que la france a intérêt à
ce que le système macron dérive à gauche
est ce que pour nous qui sommes des gens
de la droite et du centre
nous avons intérêt à laisser la gauche
tout seul diriger le pays
nous avons la chance d'avoir un premier
ministre et le jour de carence est
quelque chose que nous demandions et il
le décide donc nous avons intérêt à
avoir vis-à-vis de ce premier ministre
pour les plus timorés du respect et pour
les autres un peu de sympathie voire
d'affection dont on peut être au
gouvernement et est membre de l heure ça
ne pose pas problème moi moi je pense
qu'aujourd'hui
on ne peut pas exclure des personnalités
qui sont des personnalités de la droite
et du centre qui représentent nos idées
et que ce n'est pas notre intérêt de
laisser le système dérivé à gauche
en tout les corvées écouter eric ciotti
député et l'ère des alpes-maritimes qui
lui réclame une clarification
moi je le souhaite comme beaucoup
aujourd'hui deux députés du groupe l'est
républicain comme la plupart des
militants notre ennemi politique que
ceux qui ont décidé de ne pas siéger
dans le groupe de notre famille
politique et il n'y en a qu'un sou neuf
fois plus partie de notre famille pour
le soin sont exclus soit ils acquittent
soit ils soient issus bien sûr dans la
crise
exclure est une faute qu'est-ce qui se
passe
nous avons perdu des électeurs où sont
ils allés ses électeurs soit dans
l'abstention parce qu'on n'a pas été
assez attractif
soit ils sont allés dès le premier tour
voter manuel macron et donc il y a
beaucoup d'électeurs de droite et du
centre qui t'ont vote emmanuel macron
donc si on veut un jour rassembler notre
famille il faut parler à l'ensemble de
nos électeurs donc rejeté les uns rejeté
les autres ça conduit à toi à quoi ça
conduit à rétrécir à chaque élection
notre espace politique et comme cela ça
va conduire à une stratégie d'une droite
dure d'une droite qui ne sera pas une
droite de rassemblement qui sera une
droite refermée sur elle même et ça ce
n'est pas bon je reste fidèle au pacte
fondateur de l'ump
c'est à dire le pacte qui anime les
républicains c'est à dire l'alliance de
la droite et du sang je suis pour le
respect des diversités et je ne suis pas
favorable aux exclusions que les uns ou
les autres puissent se mettre en congé
parce qu'à un moment ou un autre leur
situation serait pas compatible
c'est possible mais exclure c'est mettre
en cause l'idée de diversité qui doit
présider à une perspective de
rassemblement
est ce que les français n'attendent pas
de la cohérence justement vous nous
parlez l'ump qui remonte quand même
moment une quinzaine d'années et on voit
qu'aujourd'hui il y aurait quand même
peut-être une plus grande cohérence à
avoir un nouveau parti comme on l'avait
fait une époque où le nouveau centre ces
décrets
et sur l'héroïne du modem est ce que les
constructif cette branche centriste de l
air ne devrait pas aujourd'hui créer un
nouveau mouvement
je pense que la droite gagne quand elle
est associée au centre j'ai entendu dans
la période récente que les élections se
gagnent est à droite
moi j'avais toujours appris avec valéry
giscard d'estaing qui je suis né en
politique où les élections se gagnent au
centre emmanuel macron pendant que la
gauche du cd élection se gagne à gauche
pendant que la droite se disaient les
élections se gagnent à droite emmanuel
macron a dit des élections se gagnent au
centre et c'est lui qui a gagné
je pense qu'un nouveau cette règle d'or
s'est imposée et pour gagner au centre
il faut une alliance de la droite d'une
raie droite mais d'un centre d'un vrai
sens donc je pense qu'il faut
reconnaître cette diversité
ces deux lignes politiques différentes
c'est pas nouveau rené rémond a
longtemps expliqué que les bonapartistes
et les organismes constituent l
essentiel de la droite française donc
c'est pas nous qui essaient de famille
mais ces deux familles doivent
s'entendre
donc je pense que il faut tout faire
pour qu'on puisse s'entendre donc je ne
suis pas nous faire perdre autant coupe
couper les têtes mais que chacun
respecte vous avez dit tout à l'heure la
diversité que vous étiez inquiet de
l'émergence d'une droite dure 1 alors
que on apprend que l'élection du
président de l air pour un lieu les 10
et 17 décembre et que là manifestement
c'est laurent wauquiez qui est en piste
nous verrons est-ce que quelques
conseils que j'ai pu être régulier les
deux familles dont vous parlez est ce
que vous le sentez le soutiendriez lui
nous verrons et là nous nous verrons le
paysage politique du moment
moi je ne soutiendrai pas une approche
qui serait une approche exclusivement
droitière je suis pour une alliance de
la droite et du centre
et je ne vois pas comment on gagne dans
la république française sans une
alliance de la droite et du centre
donc je ne soutiendrai pas une démarche
qui conduirait à ce qu'il y ait une
radicalisation à droite du parti auquel
j'appartiens toujours mais t'encule
carnet ça il y en a aujourd'hui un côté
wauquiez d'un côté solaire de 2
nous verrons nous verrons à l'intérieur
des républicains qui peut incarner ce
combat nous verrons comment les choses
peuvent se présenter
non mais là madame pécresse s'est retiré
et xavier bertrand s'il reste laurent
wauquiez
franchement soyons soyons tous prudents
à le jeu de dire non est un peu et un
peu modeste parce que quand on voit
comment on s'est tous trompés sur les
légumes présidentielle si l'élection dlr
je pense que pour moi l élection et
l'air elle est un peu anticipée je pense
qu'elle aurait été mieux si c'était un
peu plus tard parce que je crois
vraiment que on a des clarifications à
aborder et je crois que nos électeurs
veulent qu'on parle plus de la france
que de notre parti et ce qui compte
aujourd'hui si on fait de la politique
c'est pas la politique pour que notre
parti gagne c'est la politique pour que
la france réussisse et que on apporte
nos idées à la france et donc je crois
que on donne le sentiment on a fait des
primaires conduirait une dizaine de mois
et maintenant on repart dans une
élection partisane je crois qu'on est à
côté
les préoccupations de l'opinion publique
donc ça ça me parait est une erreur
stratégique pour l'avenir une du parti
pour ce qui me concerne moi je préfère
le faire en sorte que monsieur macron
quand il nous propose des choses
positives on le soutient et quand ils
proposent des choses avec lesquelles on
n'est pas d'accord on essaie de corriger
la copie d'accords alors rien y'a un
dîner qui a été très remarqué quelques
jours c'est celui des macros et des
sarkozy aujourd'hui on entend des
comparaisons on entend dire
macron sarkozy a des traits communs et
on prête à nicolas sarkozy ce mot de
dire que macron cc mois au mieux vous
qui les connaissaient finalement assez
bien tous les deux est ce que c'est
quelque chose que vous pouvez valider en
ce serait une première que nicolas
puisse trouver mieux que lui conclu mais
il m'a musulmans et mais en l'espèce
et je trouve normal que deux hommes
d'état puissent se parler puisse
discuter je pense que quand on a des
responsabilités je me souviens avoir
déjeuné avec manuel valls dès qu'il
était installé à matignon on échange
dans l'intérêt du pays je pense que ce
sont des choses qui sont utiles les
responsabilités sont tellement lourdes
sont tellement difficile que de parler
avec quelqu'un qui les a assumées ça
éclaire ça c'est sa force
celui qui est aux responsabilités donc
je pense vraiment que si cette
information est exacte
un dîner est prévu avec françois
hollande aussi bon et je pense que ce
sont des choses qui sont dans une botte
démocratie utile et qu'il faut respecter
ce genre de contact sur la ligne
politique justement dans cette
comparaison entre entre macro et sarkozy
on entend et finalement d'ailleurs
beaucoup de voix de droite dire la
politique de macron sait beaucoup de
choses qui viennent de notre programme
beaucoup de choses qui viennent de la
droite
est ce que vous pensez qu'aujourd'hui la
politique de macron est une politique de
droite
écoutez je peux pas dire ça je pense je
dirai que c'est une politique central
sur tout cela rien de chambriste
centrale centrale le soyons très prudent
parce qu'au fond emmanuel macron son
premier mois était sans parlement
maintenant nous nous avons une majorité
qui s'installe tout juste donc soyons
très très prudent
c'est au rendez-vous budgétaire dans la
discussion budgétaire que nous verrons
quand même l'état de la situation et
comment on passe de la parole au concret
à la proposition donc pour le moment
moi je ne veux pas faire de projets
qu'ils puissent être ou favorable ou
défavorable pas de procès d'intention
faisant une sorte de présomption de
bienveillance au président de la
république
le vrai premier rendez vous c'est le
rendez vous du budget est-ce qu'il sera
au rendez-vous de ses engagements
est-ce que les propositions se rendent
par le pays acceptable c'est sa veste à
la vraie question pour le moment
soyons prudents et ne mettons pas le
président de la république dans toutes
les polémiques
l'intérêt de la france c'est que ma
qu'on réussisse et dans cet intérêt là
il faut aussi protéger le président on
ne joue pas ici aujourd'hui chamboule
tout l'objectif serait de déstabiliser
le pays
je crois si le président de la
république et jouets sont pas les partis
républicains qui gagnerait ce sont les
extraits donc je pense que c'est pas
l'intérêt de la droite républicaine
aujourd'hui de rendre les choses plus
compliquées pour le président de la
république est juste une dernière qui
est rapide
on vous parlait du risque des extrêmes
aujourd'hui du côté de jean luc
mélenchon dont on voit le fn aussi en
crise comment vous analysez les choses
et et comment vous les voyez évoluer
dans l'est dans les mois qui viennent
ces deux forces de go de gauche de la
gauche et de droite de la droite
elles vont peser elle conteste certains
ou tous les cas la légitimité du pouvoir
je pense qu'il y à une radicalisation
dans le pays qui est réel il ya une
colère qui est réel nous avons connu sur
le quinquennat précédent des des
soubresauts important et il faut pas
croire que cette élection des vins de
mâcon a tout effacé donc en profondeur
dans la société les tensions restent
fortes mais un espoir s'est néanmoins
levé alors ce que je crois c'est que le
front national est en grande difficulté
parce que madame le pen notamment à
l'occasion du débat télévisé a montré
ses limites et qu'au fond elle a montré
qu'elle n'avait pas la puissance
présidentielle et quant à monsieur
mélenchon il est sans doute un animateur
politique formidable mais on va voir ses
lignes politiques et notamment comment
avec ses alliés communistes qui
représente une pensée politique qui
représentait une implantation dans le
pays
comment il va pouvoir
essayer de travailler avec eux sachant
que il a obtenu d'une certaine manière
la destruction du ps il vaudrait
peut-être la destruction du pc tout ça
va provoquer un certain nombre de
tensions
donc je pense que les deux vont
connaître des difficultés mais que
malgré cela malgré les difficultés du
front de gauche et les files difficultés
du front de droite il y aura une colère
dans le pays qu'il ne faut pas
sous-estimer
merci beaucoup mars et est reparti de
l'épreuve de vérité maintenant avec
mikel ms de public sénat qui nous
rejoint bonsoir michael st michel ou
encore jean pierre raffarin bon 5 vous
avez beaucoup parlé des autres et bien
bon moi j'ai considéré que le temps
était pour moi celui de me retirer de la
politique élective je vais avoir 60 9
ans je pense que c'est un âge
raisonnable et puisque nous sommes à une
césure présidentielle je pense que c'est
le moment puisque les jeunes prennent
les rênes du pays de leur laisser leur
chance choc générationnel
je pense qu'il ya aujourd'hui une sorte
de renouvellement des générations qui
s'installe et je pense que il faut
participer à ce mouvement ils y allaient
de bon coeur et ne pas faire une
résistance bénézit et non non non je
pense et ce à deux depuis longtemps je
pensais que chacun peut voir bien sûr je
ne donne aucune leçon à quiconque mais
je pensais que le moment venez ou moi
je voulais partir de mes fonctions
électorale en pleine forme avec des
projets et pas partir programme
justement est doucement par la faiblesse
gagnante mais au contraire partir quand
les choses vont bien a pas loupé vos
projets alors in g leader sport pierce
quand on entend leader sports pierre ça
veut dire des dirigeants vous aimez
d'accord qu'est ce que vous allez faire
vous allez devenir un lanceur d alerte
voilà nous avons hausse ce qui est
frappant aujourd'hui c'est que l'opinion
publique en france mais dans d'autres
pays n'a pas conscience toujours de la
gravité des circonstances on n'a pas
conscience de la gravité de ce qui est
en train de se passer encore et on n'a
pas conscience de la gravité de ce qui
se passe à la frontière de la libye de
la tunisie pour prendre des exemples
ces deux exemples à nous montre bien que
finalement quand il ya une crise il y a
une forme d'émotion nationale ont
notamment en france on dire on est en
guerre et puis quinze jours trois
semaines après on oublie cette gravité
et on le voit encore quand il s'agit de
couper les budgets de la sécurité
donc ce que nous voulons c'est
construire une pédagogie de la crise et
donc d'expliquer à l'opinion publique ce
que c'est que la crise de l'accord est
ce que c'est que la crise libyenne
et pourquoi c'est dangereux pour nous
tous et donc je vais demander à une
quinzaine vingtaine de leaders des
anciens premiers ministres des gens qui
ont eu l'habitude de ces dossiers et qui
savent parler à l'opinion publique
d'adresser à l'opinion publique des
messages sur la prise de conscience de
la gravité du monde d'anciens premiers
ministres vous comptons miser aussi des
anciens premier français je voudrais
qu'une équipe mondiale donc pour le
moment je travaille avec le chien j'ai
trouvé je discute encore avec jean
j'annoncerai tout ça à l'automne puisque
notre première conférence aura lieu je
l'espère au mois d'avril 2018
donc j'aurai un américain un canadien un
indien un japonais un chinois un
allemand des africains tout ça sur la
table c'est déjà sur âgées des
hypothèses des gens que je connais des
gens que j'ai identifié
donc je vais consacrer septembre octobre
a contacté ces gens là parce que je veux
des gens qui soient capables d'aller
dire aux médias mais d'aller dire aussi
aux écoles ça
prenez conscience de la gravité du monde
et toutes les crises qui peuvent être
contagieuses
je veux pouvoir en paille très
franchement moi je suis d'une génération
extrêmement gâtés on a les sorties on a
vu nos parents faire la guerre on a vu
nos enfants avoir des difficultés pour
l'emploi et nous on a eu de la
croissance et de la paix je pense que je
suis né et toute ma jeunesse j'ai
toujours pensé que la guerre était
impossible
après l'expérience que la mienne la
guerre mondiale est possible
la guerre peut venir et quelquefois elle
peut venir d'une bêtise quand vous voyez
un jour elle est par exemple des avions
russes qui sont descendus par les turcs
vous avez des événements comme ça qui
peuplent d'équipés voulaient faire de la
pédagogie ou à réunir des acteurs aussi
qui pourrait peser sur les choses
principales joueuses non non non c'est
non non je veux pas être ni expert ni
diplomate mais lanceur dallaire
s'adresser à l'opinion publique et
intéressez vous à un pays comme la
tunisie
si la tunisie devient un état islamique
c'est la france que directement menacés
la tunisie c'est vraiment un peuple
frère qui est à nos portes et il y a une
frontière aujourd'hui qui est un vrai
sujet donc le développement de la
tunisie c'est un sujet de paix mondiale
la manière dont on va gérer les
relations entre la chine et la corée
c'est un sujet pour la paix mondiale et
donc nous avons aujourd'hui des états
puissances qui veulent tout ramener au
rapport de force bilatérales nous avons
un président américain qui est assez
imprévisible
donc je voudrais vraiment me consacrer à
sa donc ans dans mon départ de la
politique élective
je continuerai à dire ce que je pense
sur le plan politique je vous dirais on
voyait alors vous vous m'entendrez et
vous verrez que je parais encore plus
libre qu'avant rsa je vais le faire je
vais m'occuper de cela j'ai reçu des
propositions professionnelles à laquelle
je n'attendais pas forcément non non
mais l'univers de toute façon je
donnerai des réponses vous venez du
serveur privé je viens du secteur privé
donc je redonnerai dernière
subjective tout ça est à l'examen nous
verrons ça mais de toute façon je suis
jusqu'à l'automne sénateurs donc tout
ceci on verra je vous le dirai ce qu'il
en est et pour moi l'essentiel c'est
cette ambition d'être quelqu'un qui va
aider à la prise de conscience
collective de la gravité du monde jean
pierre raffarin si vous permettez à
faire un petit retour en arrière du coup
sûr votre carrière politique
si vous voulez bien est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire quel est votre
peut-être pire moment dans la vie
politique puis le meilleur aussi
commençons par le pire fiche on savait
il ya des mouvements moment très très
dur donc je ne peux pas les hiérarchiser
quand vous allez visiter le site d'un
centre et qu'est-ce qui vient de brûler
avec des enfants à l'intérieur pour rien
connaître de peers j'ai vu des des
événements quand vous êtes premier
ministre quand vous êtes élu
sur le terrain vous avez ce type
d'événement qui qui vous prennent à la
gorge et qui font que vous êtes face à
l'inacceptable incompréhensible c'est
sans les choses qui matignon c'était
vraiment l'enfer matignon c'est vraiment
très difficile à matignon une bonne
nouvelle ne dure pas plus d'une heure
une heure et demie tout de suite une
mauvaise nouvelle arrive donc à matignon
la pression est forte et il ya
naturellement des détentions en
permanence à traiter ce que j'avais
aussi des ministres de talent voire leur
place nicolas sarkozy
dominique de villepin et quelques autres
ça ne manquait pas de talent cette
équipe donc je les tenues trois ans mais
c'était quand même un travail que tu as
heureusement j'avais un président de la
république qui faisait grande confiance
à son premier ministre et récits part
justement puisque vous parlez des
présidents de la république si je peux
me permettre je vais vous demandez
peut-être votre tiercé dans l'ordre si
je vous cite par exemple de gaulle
pompidou giscard mitterrand chirac
sarkozy hollande macro donc un peu tôt
pour juger bon de jouer je me moque
revenus elle me croit qu'un petit je ne
veux pas juger et me tuer chacun ainsi
si je prends deux personnalités que j'ai
naturellement très bien connu jusqu'à
j'ai un immense respect pour ce qu'il
est comme architecte comme visionnaire
comme quelqu'un qui pense une société
qui construit une démarche qui construit
y compris quand il est au bois rouge
avec avec sasson lead deux français sur
trois mais si vous prenez de l'autre
côté jacques chirac je sais si même
temps il y a eu il y a eu entre les deux
des incompréhensions et des batailles
mémorables
chirac était vraiment lui un ingénieur
d'humanité c'est quelqu'un qui connaît
la pâte humaine qui connaît l'histoire
humaine
je venais l'histoire des civilisations
et qui est vraiment le côté ingénieurs
de de l'humanité quand l'hôte et
architecte de deux choses dont vous
voyez ce sont des natures
si si vous parlez de l'architecturé
politique c'est évidemment évidemment
giscard si vous parlez du d'humanité et
d'intérêts payés c'est évidemment chirac
en ce qui me concerne on va écouter
quelques réactions de vos toujours
collègues qui s'exprime à votre sujet
moi je comptais beaucoup
beaucoup sur lui pour être un trait
d'union entre toutes les tendances entre
tous les courants
moi je ne suis pas sûr de la saline
positive je suis plutôt gaulliste mais
je considérais que si on voulait tous
restés à l'intérieur des républicains on
avait beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup besoin
de gens comme jean perras fin mais aussi
c'était quelqu'un qui parlait vrai
c'était quelqu'un qui manier l'humour et
on avait bien besoin aussi de ces petits
clins d'oeil qui nous faisait
régulièrement au delà bien évidemment du
rôle important qu'il a conduit pour
notre pays pour l'intérêt général pour
les française et pour les français
moi je retiens de lui qu'il a toujours
voulu comme premier ministre comme
parlementaire lorsqu'il prenait des
positions le faire dans l'intérêt
général dans l'intérêt de la france n'a
intérêt des françaises et des français
c'est quelqu'un qui avait une haute idée
de la france et qui a servi son pays
c'est ça que j'aime moi dans les
responsables politiques de haut rang
alors le droit de gauche les réactions
et de limiter à cestas et émouvant je
suis rentré de ces journées là le soir
chez moi j'ai dit à mon épouse je rentre
du cimetière et c'est très rare qu'on
rentre du cydia
j'ai très fort très franchement gens
sont émus merci et bien sûr bassesse et
je sais ma vie est donc le respect des
uns des autres comme que moi je
respectais beaucoup de gens je pense que
c'est quelque chose qui qui vous prend
aux tripes donc mais aussi il faut
penser que d'un élève la vie politique
elle peut aussi être aujourd'hui est
nécessairement renouvelé je crois
vraiment qu'on est arrivé un peu au bout
d'une période
et quand on vous voyez la révolte qu'il
ya dans l'opinion sur le parlementarisme
sur un certain nombre de choses comme ça
donc il faut quand même se dire qu'il
faut trouver des recettes et je pense
que l'humanité progresse quand les
générations nouvelles trouve des
solutions aux problèmes que les
générations d'avant n'ont pas réussi à
raison je suis confiant dans l'avenir
pourquoi parce que je suis confiante
dans les jeunes dans les plus jeunes et
qu'on trouvera les solutions
j'ai confiance aux progrès j'ai
confiance en la science j'ai confiance
en la capacité de résoudre les problèmes
donc
le fait de participer à ce que un pays
comme la france soit prise en main par
de jeunes générations on y met des gens
d'expérience c'est je crois quelque
chose d'important tout cas je ne voulais
pas donner le sentiment vis-à-vis de
moi-même que je résistais à ce mouvement
et quand vous voyez j'étais là en chine
j'ai représenté le président macron au
forum qui a organisé le présent c'est
jean ping sur la route de la soie
il y avait là plus d'une trentaine de
chefs d'état quand je voyais comment il
parlait de la france cette france qui
s'est élevé contre la vague du populiste
contre la vague nationaliste contre la
vague du protectionnistes avec un jeune
président 39 ans j'étais quand même fier
de la france
et ça c'est très important et pour moi
c'est ce que je mets au dessus de tout
et les visées par exemple n'y avais
jamais pensé même vos réseaux n'ont
jamais sage et j'ai jamais pensé c'était
une violence extrême les et j'ai fait il
y a dans la fonction présidentielle
quelque chose qui est terrible c'est
d'une certaine manière la destruction de
soi même vous vivez avec une caricature
vous vivez avec quelqu'un qui est créé
créé par vous mais crée aussi par les
autres par les médias par les
adversaires et donc progressivement vous
vous détruisez pour créer quelqu'un
d'autre secret qu'un d'autres vous
échappe en est donc c'est quelque chose
de terrible
et au fond et il ya là une violence
extrême parce que vous vous échapper de
vous même et c'est quelque chose que
j'ai compris très tôt et auquel je n'ai
jamais voulu toucher ne pas m'approcher
trop près du soleil parce que je sais
que là il ya un processus de de
destruction peut-être que dans ma
famille peut-être que j'ai été trop
peureux et que j'ai voulu protéger mon
bonheur plutôt que de me mettre en
risque comme tout ce sont bien oui mais
je n'ai pas le regrette
merci à vous en tous les cas pour cette
dernière émission vous l'avez dit
vous-même alors que les journalistes ont
révoqué pendant cette émission les gens
et politiques sont souvent tenus à
l'écart en ce moment et bien on vous
remercie nous parce que vous avez
toujours était toujours disponible et
très généreux
donc vos réponses et vous l'avez encore
démontré ce soir jean pierre raffarin
très bel été et on retrouvera pour la
suite de vos aventures merci michael et
nous on se retrouve à la rentrée pour la
reprise de l'épreuve de vérité et sur
public sénat avec l' agence
france-presse
c'est toujours bien sûr avec radio
classique et les échos très bel été
[Musique]
vous rendez vous avec public sénat
25 juillet 1995
la france connaît son premier attentat
islamiste commis sur son propre sol ces
attentats ce jeu pas seulement
l'affrontement entre le groupe islamique
armé le gia algérien et la france c'est
quelque chose qui nous prépare à celle
que nous connaissons maintenant
mais comment la lutte antiterroriste at
elle évolué depuis
quels sont aujourd'hui les moyens de
lutte terrorisme le risque mouvant jeudi
à 19h sur public sénat